[Musique]
j'ai vu un seau de très haut là et on
tombe dans une piscine voilà j'aime bien
faire ça
et la chaleur n'auront pas eu raison de
leur motivation
les voilà partis pour un parcours à
travers l'île de loisirs de 50 ans en
Yvelines les bulky Games avaient posé
leur structure gonflable le 9 septembre
dernier
le premier là
échelle corde glissade passer l'aspect
récréatif les difficultés techniques se
sont enchaînées 5 km et 12 obstacles à
passer avec le petit bonheur
et à tous ceux qui hésitent faites-le
dès que ça vient dans votre région c'est
génial
6300 grands enfants ont relevé le
challenge en venant de partout en France
et de plus loin c'est un devoir pour
nous on voulait s'amuser on est une asso
du personnel d'un établissement public
et on a envie de voilà de créer de la
cohésion entre
[Rires]
collègues pas de vainqueur juste du fun
les structures ont été dégonflés
direction la ville de Rouen